for the first time in many weeks the r
number in the uk
is above one between 1 and 1.2
the regional numbers tell the same story
scotland
could be as high as 1.5 we got another
estimate of the are today from imperial
college
which pers puts it as high as 1.7
all this data tells us the virus is
definitely growing
although as always with these figures we
should be careful about reading too much
into one week another source of
information is the office for national
statistics survey
which tests 10 000 households every week
to get a representative national sample
last week it estimated that around 2 000
people a day were being infected in
england
this week that's up to three thousand
two hundred a jump of sixty percent
and more importantly these infections
aren't just in clusters
the epidemic is spreading nationally
of course we should keep this in
perspective this is still a very small
percentage of the population
much less than at the peak just 0.1
and if you look carefully at the ons
stats you see that infections are stable
among over 50 the most vulnerable part
of the population
the real rise is here in black among
younger people
probably as a result deaths and hospital
emissions aren't rising
although on that the data from other
countries
is not encouraging you look at france
for example their numbers started
increasing before us did and so they
give us a kind of view into our future
in some sense
and the concerning thing is for a little
while our cases have been going up but
our
hospitalizations and our deaths have
been fairly constant whereas now
the hospitalizations have started to
move up in this country
and if you look at france then you can
see that even their deaths have started
to go up and that's
that's the last of the stages so
what does this mean for all of us this
analysis
of different types of events from the
government's scientific advisors
gives a good insight into what they're
thinking orange is for high-risk
activity so
this one here trade shows in the middle
you can see that's not very high risk
very little orange there
that's probably because there are they
don't happen very often and there aren't
many older people there
but look the biggest danger family
celebrations look it's almost red right
across the board
christmas is a real worry
the governments of the uk do have a new
tool scotland's new contact tracing app
arrived this week
following in the footsteps of northern
ireland and england and wales will have
one in two weeks
and this is a significant moment given
all the problems especially in england
it's also a reminder as we face this new
spike
we're a lot better prepared